mente l'altro giorno mi chiama la
Rosanna no E ho già detto che cosa vorrà
questa qui fa ciao cara senti volevo
farti gli auguri di Natale E io che sono
una vecchia volpe G ho detto Senti
rosannina non prendiamoci in giro di
cosa hai bisogno Guarda Anna sono un po'
in difficoltà me li presteresti mica
€300 m000 te lo giuro ma io G ho detto
ma scusa ma per chi mi hai preso per
Babbo Natale gli ho detto carissima
00.000 per me sono briciole ma non ti li
dop per una questione di principio
perché nel lontano 72 mio padre chiese a
tuo paparino un prestito irrisorio cosa
gli rispose Lui no che a casa mia si
dice Occhio per occhio dente per ente ti
se è messa a piangere dalla vergogna Ma
me non mi interessa sai nella vita
ognuno ha ciò che si merita Ti ricordi
quando la Ramon ha aperto il negozio di
intimo in centro sai che gli aveva dato
i soldi per aprire il negozio papà ti
dico di sì tu eri troppo piccola per
ricordarti Ma io mi ricordo tutto la
scorsa settimana ero nei paraggi del suo
negozio e la incontro non ci crederai
mai mi ha guardato abbassato lo sguardo
non mi ha neanche salutata ti prestiamo
i soldi non ce li ridi e non saluti
neanche niente tutto questo per dirti
che ieri l' è andata a fuoco il negozio
e con tutto l'acrilico che c'ha dentro
figurati fiamme di qui fiamme di là una
cosa assurda